[Music]
Sharna Burgess spills her secrets to
success on Dancing with the Stars how do
you strategize with when you're
choreographing and also when you're
sitting there talking to them with the
judges yeah I try to not to interact
with the judges because it never goes
down world and you accept it listen at
the end of the day they're hired for
their their critiques and they're
watching the dance and they're all going
to say something different land is
always looking for that technique or
cariann is look looking for those lifts
bruno's looking for the personality you
have to accept that they all have their
opinion of your dance and just nod smile
take it on the chin and try and work and
be better so they don't say it again
what is your strategy to win take each
day as it comes really with Fonda
honestly my strategy is to just have him
improve as much as we can each week and
I think my goal for him is to have him
moving better with his injuries have him
feeling stronger and more confident from
what I'm discovering he's great at least
he's a lot better at the ballroom styles
the more traditional hold a strong frame
classic style eg sat down with the pro
for a Facebook live interview and took
fun fan questions - Brittany wanted to
know would you ever be the Bachelorette
oh yeah sure why not
I don't know it who doesn't want a bunch
of beautiful men around you while pining
for your attention yeah right now you
only have one aha you know her D yeah
yeah no sure I would love to why not
[Music]